whether you're a vegetarian vegan or
just looking to add more vegetables into
your diet you've got to try this healthy
veggie burger recipes you get to satisfy
your craving for a burger but without
the saturated fats so these burgers are
high in protein and fiber but low in fat
and hey they can be gluten-free as well
and the best part about these burgers is
that they're extremely versatile and
easy to make so I'm going to show you
three variations of my favorite veggie
burgers so let's start with the curried
chickpea burger this burger is packed
with spices such as Kayne cumin and also
Korean and you get the nutty taste of
chickpeas as well so what have used our
one can of chickpeas wash and drained
two garlic cloves minced 2 tablespoons
of olive oil 1/2 a teaspoon of cumin 1/2
a teaspoon of curry powder and half a
teaspoon of cayenne pepper add the
chickpeas into a food processor or
blender along with the garlic all the
spices and 1 tablespoon of oil blend
until you get a thick mixture using your
hands form the mixture into four burger
patties each patty has about 112
calories the next recipe has to be my
favorite because it combines both
mushrooms and also black beans
the thing is mushrooms are surprisingly
similar to the texture of meat when
cooked so eating this mushroom black
bean burger will not make you miss the
taste of a regular meat burger what I've
used are 3/4 cup of fresh mushrooms
finely diced 3 quat a can of black beans
rinsed and drained 2 tablespoons of
olive oil 1/2 a cup of onion diced 1
garlic clove minced 1 tbsp of green
onions roughly chopped half a teaspoon
of cumin salt and pepper to taste
so the key step here is to saute the
mushrooms and onions before mixing it
together with the beans which will
infuse much more flavor to the patties
so the first step here is to saute the
garlic
and onion for three to five minutes
until they are soft and fragrant then
add in the chopped mushrooms green
onions and cumin continue to saute for
another five minutes or until the
mushrooms are cooked through then remove
from heat and allow the mixture to cool
down in a bowl roughly mash the black
beans I like to keep them chunky then
combine the mashed black beans with the
onion and mushroom mixture and flavor it
with salt and pepper mix until all the
ingredients are well combined again
using your hands shape the mixture into
four equal patties about 3/4 to 1 inch
thick mushrooms pack plenty of flavors
and texture and the black beans makes
this burger much high in fiber and also
protein which will keep you fuller for
much longer
each patty has about 112 calories and my
final recipe is the tofu burger tofu is
a staple ingredient in most vegan or
vegetarian diets it's extremely
versatile and it takes on the flavor of
whatever ingredients you combine it with
this tofu burger packs on the flavors
from the garlic and onions plus it has
the additional neutron boost from char
seeds
what abuse are one block of extra firm
tofu half a cup of onion diced 1 tbsp of
green onions roughly chopped and 1 part
of cha mixture which is a combination of
1 tablespoon of chia seeds with 3
tablespoons of water 2 tablespoons of
soy sauce 1 tablespoon of oil 1 garlic
clove minced and salt and pepper to
taste
blend the tofu along with the rest of
the ingredients onions green onions
garlic salt and pepper charm mixture and
soya sauce blend until you form a tofu
paste next gently form the tofu mixture
into patties pressing everything
together to form round patties about 3/4
to 1 inch thick this should make you
about 4 patties
this tofu burger it's very light fluffy
and easy to be eaten each Patsy has
about 104 calories on a nonstick pan
heat 1 tablespoon of oil under
medium-high heat then cook the patties
on both sides until they are slightly
Brown and crunchy
just for about 5 minutes remove from
heat and set aside now let's put these
burgers together you can even use
English muffins or mini burger buns so
I've topped my burgers with baby spinach
and sliced tomatoes choose any
vegetables of your choice
just look at them they are healthy
delicious and even perfect to be served
at a party snack trust me you will not
leave missing your regular meat burgers
after trying one of these they are moist
tender and packed with flavor you got to
try them make them snap and share your
pictures with me
tag me as a journalist or official and
hashtag it chase your recipes let me
know which is your favorite in the
comments below ok
be sure to snap because I want to see
all your veggie burger creations don't
forget to like this video share this
video and hit the subscribe button if
you haven't yet done it turn on your
notification button so that you would
get notified every time I upload a new
healthy and delicious recipe all the
best